the predator gets a makeover and gets
outfoxed by a dog prey is more than just
predator 5. here's how the prequel kept
the franchise fresh
in predator 2 the predatorship features
artifacts and weapons spanning many
times in cultures as a result each new
predator film can really pit the
creature against any group of humans
enter prey which follows comanche
warrior naru as she battles european
soldiers and the predator in north
america in 1719 in prey our beloved
predator is traveling light on a
vacation to earth while the humanoid
alien is shown using its invisibility
cloak mode on multiple occasions the
creature doesn't rely on any of its
other gadgetry as much as it has in
previous films that isn't to say that
all of the high-tech alien weapons are
absent merely that this heiress predator
prefers to stab and impale its prey
rather than blast them to smithereens it
fought and killed a bear with its hands
since the film does take place 300 years
ago it's possible that this version of
the predator is not quite fully evolved
in the weapons department while the
alien hunter is certainly far more
advanced than humanity in 1719 it
doesn't appear to have all the tricks
and upgrades of alien vs predator more
importantly this makes it a much fairer
contest between the humans and the alien
creature since it isn't drawing upon an
endless arsenal of options however it
would be interesting to witness how the
creature fares without the use of its
cloak technology at all since that still
allows it to sneak up on humans animals
at least can sniff the creature out even
if they can't see the predator
the success of john mctiernan's predator
film can be attributed to its survival
horror elements dutch and his team are
out in a jungle surrounded by trees
constricting the space puts them at the
mercy of the alien whose use of
camouflage and the environment makes
members of the group sitting ducks
similarly other predator movies
especially the good ones that try to
honor the original rely on this key
element as the alien has a place to hide
sneak and strike from to borrow a terry
silver quote from the karate kid part 3
a man can't see he can't fight
prey features some similar situations to
the first predator where there are
moments of confinement but it also poses
a new question in asking how good the
predator is in open spaces the great
plains boast vast amounts of open land
with only grass in the distance in
theory this would be the best place to
lure the alien creature to since it
removes the high ground aspect and lets
any sudden movement be more identifiable
however prey confirms that the creature
is as lethal in this setting as in
others
one especially memorable scene finds the
beast chasing naru and a fellow comanche
warrior across an open field a set piece
reminiscent of the velociraptors
stalking the hunters through the long
grass in the lost world jurassic park
the predators hunt other life forms for
both sport and pride claiming
ritualistic trophies from their
victories they want to prove their
superiority quite often in the most
brutal way imaginable while maintaining
a code of honor for their prey this code
is questionable though since it isn't
even a fair fight if the opponent fails
to have intergalactic weapons in their
possession so it goes without saying
that their moral compass is a bit skewed
in other predator films the audience
witnesses the alien hunter go after
humans as their main target identifying
them as worthy adversaries ironically
humans aren't even considered apex
predators in our own world since we
don't eat everything we destroy but in
prey the predator goes after several
creatures not just humans it faces off
in two big contests against a wolf and a
bear the wolf shows its nose is key in
this encounter however it proves to be
no match for the predator's sharp blades
on the other hand the bear strikes some
real blows to the creature if the
predator's cloaking ability had been
removed there's a good chance it might
have struggled to deal with the bear's
sheer power
next to its age-old nemesis the
xenomorph the predator's design is one
of cinema's most distinctive and iconic
creatures from its trademark dreadlocks
to its seriously gruesome face the
universe traversing hunter would be
pretty easy to pick out in a lineup
however in prey the predator looks a
little different
showcasing a leaner gladiator aesthetic
while it's still easily identifiable it
did receive a makeover with a few tweaks
to its physical appearance that fans
noticed immediately dan trachtenberg
explained why he felt it was necessary
to change the creature's appearance for
the film telling time out i wanted to
make sure the head was more proportional
to the body this predator is much
slimmer and less armored than it's ever
been it's more creature it's still
hulking and ferocious at san diego
comic-con trachtenberg also revealed
that he and his team included goop
around the predator's face to make it
more disturbing to look at
in predator 2 the creature navigates a
concrete jungle with relative ease and
fluidity despite the unique surroundings
of los angeles it understands what it
needs to do to hunt and survive in this
setting the reason for this is likely
due to the events of prey which serve as
an important lesson for all the other
predators of what not to do when on
earth in prey the predator falls into a
quicksand style mud trap which
ultimately plays a major part in its
downfall like anyone else in such a
pickle it struggles to get out of this
situation especially as it had been
injured beforehand which made its
predicament even worse but it does lead
one to wonder if perhaps quicksand
didn't exist on any of the other planets
the predator had visited before it's
also possible that this predator is
still young and inexperienced in its
hunts maybe earth is its first rite of
passage and it's trying to prove itself
quickly and recklessly that would also
explain why the creature fights the bear
in the river when the water isn't
conducive to its cloak mode's
effectiveness and helps to reveal its
presence
throughout all the predator films the
alien has taken on many formidable foes
who have proven to be worthy adversaries
and even victors from the terrifying
xenomorph to walking muscle mountain
dutch shaffer played by arnold
schwarzenegger the alien hunter has
faced off against the best of the best
across the planet in prey the predator
gets too cocky for its own good failing
to properly determine all of its threats
not only does the predator dismiss
naaru's abilities but it also overlooks
her dog while the predator manages to
put down a wolf a bear and countless
other human beings throughout the movie
it eventually falls to the outstanding
teamwork of naaru and her dog one could
even argue that it's the dog that makes
the difference here as naru is left
exposed in the final fight on two
occasions after previously saving the
comanche warrior from the predator the
four-legged mutt appears at the end of
the film with an axe when naru needs it
most in many ways naru's faithful friend
is the true hero of this story
remaining quiet is often the key to
successfully capturing prey while
hunting since it helps to maintain the
element of surprise allowing the hunter
to strike hard and fast in the previous
predator movies silence hasn't always
been possible while everyone tries to
keep their lip sealed and their mobile
phones on silent when in danger groups
of people tend to talk or move around
even when their imminent threat of total
annihilation looms near there's
something else out there
on the other hand prey is a quiet film
besides the occasional bird chirp or
rustle of the leaves there's an intense
stillness and quiet to the great plains
in many ways this setting is ideal for
the predator as the silence ensures the
creature is able to hear the footsteps
of its prey from a mile away however
it's equally effective for the intended
victim too since any sudden movement
will alert them of a problem on the
horizon as an example naaru manages to
find and attack the unaware predator
simply because she's quieter than the
alien talk about using the hunter's
tactics against them
there's an argument to be made that the
predator franchise falls firmly under
the umbrella of horror after all the
whole concept of an almighty alien
hunter chasing after humans is
frightening plus the creature's unmasked
face is pure nightmare fuel plus the
franchise's previous films are
jam-packed with jump scares with victims
never knowing what's lurking around
every corner in prey some of those scary
elements remain but there's something
different about this version this time
the predator seems far more savage than
before this alien creature uses its raw
power and lightning speed to wicked
effect it moves with a resolute purpose
and uncanny brutality that has been
lacking in the franchise's recent
toutings while brutality is a key
element of the slasher genre the
predator isn't coming at people through
their nightmares or hiding behind doors
and walls it doesn't hide in the shadows
like a boogeyman instead it charges into
battle like a warrior that isn't afraid
of anything which is somehow more
horrifying
it's a foregone conclusion that the
better a warrior's class of weapons the
better chance they have of success in
the previous predator films the hunter's
shoulder cannons have made all the
difference in battle in prey the
creature prefers to use hand-to-hand
combat to dispose of its opponents but
it isn't averse to pulling out the big
guns when absolutely necessary but that
doesn't mean their superior weapons win
out in the end while literally stuck in
sinking mud the predator points its
weapon at naaru and fires however it
fails to realize that it isn't wearing
its helmet which features incredibly
accurate targeting capabilities it also
doesn't notice that naaru has carefully
set up the helmet to lock the predator
in its crosshairs as a result the
creature ends up on the receiving end of
its own attack again it proves that
technology can be useful in a fight but
a strategist will always trump an
aggressive brute in the end
consistent across the predator franchise
is that the extraterrestrial beings
believe in a warrior's code they don't
hunt for a tasty snack or out of
self-defense instead they take on
opponents they believe will provide a
tough daunting challenge or who would
make excellent sparring partners like in
the yakuza sword fight in predators for
these alien hunters it's about testing
their superior skills and advanced
smarts as they attempt to prove they are
worthy enough to be a part of their clan
throughout the predator films this code
seems to remain intact however prey
explores what happens if the alien isn't
actually all that good at identifying
threats or challengers for whatever
reason
this is as far as you go
undoubtedly the predator sees the
comanche warriors as worthy enough to
challenge and hunt it stalks and battles
them coming out on top on several
occasions however the creature fails to
see naaru as a threat from the get-go
she demonstrates a warrior's spirit and
natural fighting ability even if some of
her own people doubt her skills however
the predator basically scoffs at the
thought of taking her on but it's
naaru's resilience and ingenuity that
bring down the alien hunter in combat
imagine how different prey would have
been had the predator never
underestimated naru in the first place
[Music]